ich werde dann angerufen kann ja nicht
reingehen doch ich jetzt eben dran ich
mach hallo frohe weihnachten erst mal
ihre leute und herzlich willkommen zu
einem weiteren konnte hier auf meinem
kanal und zwar kam ja eigentlich gestern
der kontakt allerdings kamen dann nicht
weil ich das einfach grundsätzlich
vergessen habe ich war den ganzen tag
irgendwo unterwegs hatte keine zeit
dafür
und deswegen hoffe ich dass sie mir das
verzeiht und ich hab ja im letzten
kontakt also deswegen lade ich ihn
erstmal heute hoch weil ich habe auf
facebook meiner facebook-seite das könnt
ihr immer mitbestimmen wann ich was
irgendwie hochladen mich halt gefallen
wollte lieber dass sie kontakt jetzt
noch hoch lade als am montag oder wollt
ihr lieber dass der nächste woche
einfach ein doppelt so lange mache und
dann halten alle neven schon jetzt noch
einmal ein paar wollten haben und
blablabla deswegen lade ich herrn
erfahren jetzt doch und im letzten
kontakt meinten hals ein paar leute so
also ich hab so eine umfrage gemacht
wieder oben in der beschreibung ob ihr
entweder einen ganz normalen kontakt
haben wollt wo ich zu meinem woche so
ein bisschen zusammenfasste oder ob ihr
eure kommentare beantwortet haben wollt
oder ob ihr meine lieblingsmusik haben
wollten da hat mit 1000 millionen
trilliarden stimmen ja meine
lieblingsmusik gewonnen deswegen ich
habe jetzt hier ich kann ich meine
lieblingsmusik sagen weil ich bin nicht
so einer der jetzt von einem sänger oder
von einem interpreten oder von einem dj
oder von einer band richtig richtig viel
hört sondern mehr so von den paar lieder
von denen paar lieder so ein bisschen so
ich bin sowieso ein huhn das duo madcon
findet ich nichts wissen die einzelnen
lieder raus und die remixe und mashups
und so dass sich halt am meisten und ich
denke dass ihr euch darauf sachen dabei
sind an alle die dubstep hören ihr könnt
direkt weg stellten ich habe ich so viel
dubstep aber sind mager elektro sache
noch dabei und ich würde sagen ich hab
ja spotify ich einfach meine listen
jetzt durch die ganze zeit hier hin weil
hier ist mein zweiter bildschirm ich hab
den dass mein erster bildschirm dass
mein zweiter ich hab einfach durch mein
altes zimmer getragen gehen was erstmal
bis 30 zentimetern und ließ davon jetzt
einfach ablesen ich geh jetzt ein paar
ein bisschen meine playlist durchlesen
euch ein paar leute vor und ich packe
ich auch aus meiner featured playlist
also das ist eine playlist die ich so
ich hab so mehrere playlisten egal ich
fange jetzt erstmal mit dem hobby das
weiß etwas vor gebrabbel viel spaß also
ich habe erst mal grundsätzlich sechs
playlisten
verschiedene workshops prüfung
geschlagen habe das hat man nicht als 60
gehört na ja es sind jedenfalls sechs
verschiedene richtungen sondern mehr so
jedoch einerseits torres aber
andererseits auch so gefühls richtungen
also ich habe einmal die eine party
claims also das hören wir zum beispiel
wenn wir so irgendwie vor trinken sind
oder irgendwie sowas oder wenn wir
irgendwie einfach so ins irgendwo
treffen und wir haben keine gute musik
am start entschied sich ein handy haben
ist die feier und hab dann einfach
nirgends motiv als relativ cool also ihr
könnt euch das einfach runterladen ist
kostet zehn euro monatlich 18 euro
und ihr habt die komplette musik die es
gibt weltweit alle am start mit der
besten qualität also ich bekomme nichts
dafür dass das sage aber einfach damit
ihr wisst spotify ist und das hören wir
halt da sind weiß nicht fliegen da drin
sind da sind moment moment moment mal
kurz über party play list und bei mir 26
titel drin das sind titel die ich halt
immer so so mainstream sachen halt so
was wie hey brother von avicii oder you
make me von naviki oder ist ein luftiges
marcel von one republic oder was habe
ich hier noch so andy mills formation
gehrig zu sachen die jeder kennt oder
crazy world von dj antoine also leute
wie die aktien sind da drin dimitri
vegas mashup germany flo rida so erneut
halt einfach wie flo rida martin
garrigues david guetta pitbull cash
avicii so halt die jeder kennt jeder auf
der party hört wo jeder irgendwie zu
abgeben kann wohl jeder irgendwie weiß
was damit gemeint ist und so das halt in
der party playlist vormieterin also dass
zum musikhören dann meine größte place
ist die playlist dir ich eigentlich
immer wenn ich irgendwie autofahrer oder
wenn ich irgendwie vom training nach
hause fahre oder irgendwie sowas wie ist
der sehr geil an alle leute die gerne
irgendwo chillige sachen hören so paul
kalkbrenner so in die richtung die das
kann man so einen finde ich das kann man
gut bei hausaufgaben hören das kann man
gut wenn es draußen regnet und man
schild drin oder so und na ja da ist
dann so was drin wie vorn und rettet mit
changes oder langer house mix von johnny
works oder you know i like it mix von
halo george oder numbers von logic so
ein bisschen soße dance von micky tanz
oder sowas
da habe ich ein remix aber mehr gitarren
story denn soll direkt kennen oder
sollte doch sonnentanz kennen von klang
karussell oder was ist dann noch relativ
bekannt ihr jubel von klingende was ist
noch los man baut von rws zeit von tyler
what is your noch drin aber nur das
instrument nur das akustik rivers von
perkussiv haus von enten da so ein paar
bekannte interpreten da sind halt and
mac miller calvin harris plan karussell
robin schulz mit itans logic alona
george john works roland wild also dass
meine playlist auf die bin ich besonders
stolz weil das ist die einzige playlist
nicht quasi täglich updater weil die
segel man sieht immer wenn man so sachen
hinzufügt und das sind sachen die ich
halt immer so jan hinzufüge und dann mal
wieder verändere weil ich die halt echt
am meisten höhere zurzeit dann kommen
wir zum nächsten und zwar black music
black music ist halt einfach american
hip hop so was in die richtung und zwar
ist der turn down forward von dj snake
nothing but i denk von snoop dogg
trainer von kanye west jonkers von tyler
the creator luftbild von disturbed
disturbing der peace train von esther
brocki von acer brock ist richtig viel
drin von seo blog ich da noch fucking
problems und sogar das alles oder goalie
oder irgendwie solche ganzen sachen von
block i halt ländern ist da ich werde
dann angerufen
kann ja nicht angehen doch jetzt eben
dran ich mag alle frohe weihnachten erst
mal
ja ja ja am besten morgens geht's okay
perfekt dankeschön da komme ich gleich
vorbei okay gut machen wir weiter das
war nicht geplant dass ich jetzt
angerufen werde aber das war gut weil
das war mein friseur und ich habe da
noch einen termin bekommen bevor ich
nach hamburg fahre ich war übrigens nach
hamburg vom zweiten bis vierten falls da
irgendwer auch in hamburg wohnt oder so
vielleicht sieht man sich ja in der
black pearl ist immer noch so sachen
drin wie kelly swat distrikt eminem ich
weiß nicht warum amy namen black drin
ist der ist eigentlich bleibt aber sowas
wie urlaub mehr so finde ich gehört
einfach für mich zu black oder von emmi
nahmen auch noch ich habe zwei mal
wieder ob mir drin das ist auch dann
habe ich noch mattafix mit big city life
das ist echt richtig geil also das ist
nicht alles black das ist ich weiß das
sind das ist nicht alles black so dass
wir das auch nicht wirklich black aber
das ist für mich irgendwie sowas ich
habe die playlist einfach black genannt
weil ich wollte das jetzt nicht so
american nennen weil auch nicht alles
amerikanisch ist aber ich hab's einfach
jetzt black genannt weil weiß nicht
einfach weggehen kipping ist auch drin
missy elliott mit lose control kanye
west oder kanye west ist der glaube ich
sogar solche sachen sind halt in black
drin ich schreibe euch übrigens aus
jeder playlist schreibe ich euch mal so
meine lieblingslieder einfach jetzt in
die beschreibung als sie findet in der
beschreibung dann wahrscheinlich
featured paar titel black hip hop und
rap und da stehen dann immer so die
besten songs ich finde also fünf songs
dazu stehen unten drin und mit einem
youtube link und dann gebe ich mir
richtig viel mühe dabei dass ihr euch
die ganze sache dann auch eventuell
anhören könnt und damit ihr sowieso was
ich so höre ja dann die nächste play ist
hier ist hebt zudem hob er sagt etwas
gestoppt obwohl es auch nicht richtig
hip hop ist ich weiß jetzt sagen wieder
leute
düsseldorfs okay ist hip hop aber
facebook vs holz vielleicht ist gar
nicht so viel hip hop video so denkst
oder musste ist eigentlich auch nicht so
viel bla bla bla
ich weiß ich hab die blende ist nur so
genannt weil die brauchten gleichen nahm
ich wollte jetzt nicht 123 nennen oder
irgend sowas ist wegen tipps zu den
haupt und so was drin wie die bank
richtig richtig wie die banken dadurch
ob es jedoch edels meint jonas ray
charles habe ich noch drauf noch von
citibank auf ängste aus
solche sachen richtig viel
auch den feier auch heftig let me be
mihai ghimpu lips lucky make you make it
a um neuen therapien richtig viele
sachen von woody allen dann auch so
leute wie abbau west die mit west side
story oder so dann hatte ich ja auch mit
ästen mit livni oder alle fleisch
fleisch ist ein cooler song logic mit
spotlights eminem ist ja auch drin mit
love game ermittler kendrick lama also
wie gesagt eminem ist indes im black
drin ersten hip hop in der dating party
drin
er ist überall mit rennen irgendwie so
ein paar lieder die ich einfach so von
meinem geschmack eher zu den speziellen
richtungen zu ordner einfach also nicht
da ich ja egal ich habs jetzt auf genug
gestreckt und meine letzte playlist also
zu featured komme ich gleich noch mal am
ende aber meine letzte playlist diese
noch mal so ein gefühl stick von mir
sein eigenes genre ist halt rap ist ich
weiß nur eines tore habe ich zum
beispiel guten morgen nsa von mo trip
ist sehr sehr geiler song euch zurzeit
pausenlos richtig geil habe ich hier von
seo das ziel heißt er auch endgegner von
bushido eigentlich wollte nett doch die
hosting von dvds von dvds habe ich noch
ein paar andere sachen aber die kennt
wahrscheinlich alle schon mal mercedes
oder den gedroht
luisi album von samy deluxe ist auch
richtig richtig schöner alter song ist
auch richtig richtig schön das ist echt
samy deluxe ist so ein wort acrobat es
ist richtig richtig geil
dann habe ich auch so ein paar nicht von
bp sondern jbb runden von units blog
battle des ballsports gegen fortune das
klingt finale nazi bei dieser giro des
von von we can habe ich jetzt ein paar
vbt und auch am start von weekend habe
ich allgemein noch fakhri kennt
beispielsweise dass sowas dann triumph
von genetik stress ohne grund von farid
bang summer jam alles verloren bauen
ließ oder lass es fix die welt interpol
dort combo alles wird gut print software
wird der style und das geld nicht an das
geld müsste ich mal raus packen diese
verdammte kleinod oder damit der punker
von haftbefehl steroid webs ein paar
sachen die man einfach so kennst du die
hauptsächlichen app stores
kollege habe ich da jetzt nicht gleich
noch eine extra kollege playlist ab 100
kollege lee darin sind aber das ist
einfach nur weil ich mir die damals die
alben gekauft habe und das muss ich
jetzt nicht folgen
das hat alles mögliche drin big boss
kollegah vier elementen junge bäumchen
nicht mondfinsternis kober kopf so die
ganze sache dann kommen wir jetzt zu der
feature playlist wo die chance drin sind
die ich halt immer mal so ab und zu
hören was das mit playlist die ich halt
ich habe mein finger wieder geknackt es
ist eine playlist die ich bei allem
einfach höhere das ist eine bestie hörig
beim fahrradfahren die höre ich manchmal
beim pumpen beim beim sport machen
allgemeinen beim joggen einfach wenn ich
irgendwie hier so chile und irgendein
video rat bearbeitet und irgendwie dass
gerade am rändern ist oder so das ist
halt einfach die kann man immer höheren
neben den anderen palace mit den anderen
teil ist es so still will man hören wenn
man drinnen wie draußen regnet wenn man
gerade vom training wieder kommt und wer
mal ein chaos oder so wenn man auto
fährt party will man hört wenn man ein
bisschen angetrunken ist ducati fährt
oder so und featured kann ich eigentlich
irgendwie immer höher da sind auch ein
paar sachen zusammen drin die auch in
den anderen fällen auch schon drin sind
da haben wir so einen house electro
mashup remix von jay kay music der auch
richtig geile musik machte ich wie
gesagt er steht auch in der beschreibung
von feature pack ich auf fünf tiger eine
beschreibung what the witcher 2 ist ein
dj smash up von martin garrigues börse
sowie hannah als aufseher stronger power
von robin göckes von mashups zweier sich
als eshops andy wilson oliver haye dance
remix manchmal habe ich wirklich damals
war das so dass ich bei sexy [ __ ] von
david guetta hat sich in fünf
verschiedenen remixen man die kamera
geht einfach aus geil nein also was sie
von gesagt habe beim sex wird jeder als
damals fünf remix ist und jeder remix
einfach anders und das ist bei martin
garrigues bei andy matt zurzeit bei mir
aber dieser oliver heldens remix die
müsst ihr euch echt auf jeden fall geben
an alle elektro dance freunde da unter
euch haus freunde in emails oliver
helden suite steht auch einer
beschreibung unter featured der vierte
oder dritte link glaube ich müsste auf
jeden fall geben ist sehr geil dann habe
ich noch ein dance music 2013 von jackie
wie gesagt eigentlich so kulac power von
cani us-rennen von ceo dave einmal um
die welt von brawn gp bergen ist auch
ein mashup geile welt von crysis michael
moore
dann hab ich den larven ihr game der
kauf remix den kennt bestimmt viele von
euch das mega geil in brüssel dass es
rüssel zusammen mit kimba gemischt mit
flo rida featuring kesha afrika von
ashley bridge e mails an johnny depp
remakes zwillingsbruder vom michael mind
project das kennt jeder von euch dieses
ja gut das war es eigentlich auch schon
viel mehr ist auch gar nicht sind also
ich hab da so ein paar songs
übersprungen die ich selber bin ich gar
nicht so viel höhere die man einfach man
hat einfach ein paar songs in der
players drin sind die man einfach immer
überspringt aber die man noch irgendwie
nicht auspackt das ist einfach weil sich
das ist eigentlich immer so ich hoffe
euch hat der kontakt gefallen bis
hierhin ich wollte euch einfach mal
meine lieblingsmusik ein bisschen näher
bringen wir jetzt großartig erwartet
habe dass ich jeden song vorspiele et
cetera dazu fehlt mir einerseits jetzt
die zeit wenn das video heute noch
online kommen soll war schon halb sieben
ist und immer hat bush leitung laut das
1000 jahre dass das video online ist und
andererseits vielmehr daran hat auch die
rechte das ist halt so ich dürfte glaube
ich keine musik von der musik ich euch
jetzt genannt habe abspielen außer
vielleicht die mimik von jackie music
aber da weiß ich auch nicht nur weil er
hat youtuber ist und die sachen hat auch
hochgeladen hat nur ich weiß ich durfte
glaub ich nichts abspielen deswegen hab
dem hintergrund einfach monster das ist
wie soll man meist gefragte frage was
hast du für hintergrundmusik meistens
monster kat
sie gibt einfach mal bei youtube monster
kat 1 einfach monster kate zusammen
geschrieben oder aperture nirvana die
haben von denen ich auch immer musik
aber monster kennt die machen auch echt
geile lieder also da könnt ihr auch
einfach mal vorbei gruppen das kann man
auch das ist nicht unbedingt zur
hintergrundmusik die kann man auch so
mal einfach hören ja sonst guckt einfach
in der beschreibung vorbei da steht mein
instagram profil wohl befolgen können
meine facebook-seite man twitter mein
google+ alles was ich halt habe
unterstehe noch ein paar links zu den
liedern drin die ich euch jetzt
vorgetragen habe das heißt ich sehe die
ganze nation total fertig aus in diesem
video
na gut ich bin noch einfach total fertig
die links und in der beschreibung guckt
euch einfach anhört soll ich alles sind
echt geile songs dabei und dann würde
ich sagen wenn es euch gefallen hat dann
lass mir einfach eine bewertung da
wirklich wenn es euch gefallen hat wenn
nicht dann lass es einfach aber das ist
wichtig dass ich sehe was ihr feiert und
was nicht und wollt ihr dann im nächsten
kontakt er dass ich eure kommentare
beantworte oder wollte immer wieder
seinen normalen kontakt wo ich einfach
mal eine woche zusammen fassen weil das
wäre wichtig wenn ich das jetzt schon
weiß also schreibt bitte jetzt so viel
ein wie ihr wollt spam zu viel rum wie
geht damit das echt ganz nah zeitlich
frühzeitliche temporär jetzt gleich weiß
damit ich jetzt eventuell
morgen dann schon die nächsten blog so
aufnehmen kann was ich in meiner
freizeit so macht er diese woche und
sonst nichts sagen